le monde
se souviendra de ce jour
du test Trinity et de la révélation de
la première explosion atomique au monde
a été l'un des moments les plus importants
du 20e siècle c'était un
projet miraculeux massif dans lequel plusieurs milliers
de personnes ont été impliquées a touché le
gouvernement il a touché  la science, cela avait
d'énormes ramifications pour toutes sortes de
gens ordinaires, le test de la Trinité, le
développement et la race et le fait
que tout cela tentait de sauver une sorte
d'humanité du fascisme. La Seconde Guerre mondiale
serait terminée, nos garçons reviendraient à la maison,
c'est une question  de la vie et de la mort mais je
peux accomplir ce miracle, ce qui était vraiment
intéressant c'était de revenir en arrière et d'essayer de
comprendre ce que ces gars pensaient
et les terribles décisions qui
leur étaient confiées. Je
ne sais pas si on peut nous faire confiance avec une telle
arme  mais je sais qu'elle a peur que nous vivions
dans le monde dans lequel nous vivons à cause de ce qui
s'est passé à Los Alamos, pourquoi irions-nous
au milieu de nulle part pendant qui
sait combien de temps parce que c'est
la chose la plus importante qui se soit jamais produite
dans l'histoire  du monde
à travers l'humanité, nous avons été aveuglés
par l'ambition et la poursuite, puis les
ramifications sont quelque chose d'autre qui
se produit, n'est-ce pas, je pense que c'est pourquoi
c'est si bizarre et incroyable que Chris
fasse ce film maintenant, nous voyons des
parallèles  une expérience profondément bouleversante
en le regardant, ce n'est pas une
leçon d'histoire, cela ne veut pas dire aux gens
que c'est ce que vous devez en tirer,
mais je pense qu'il est très clair que cela peut
refléter ce qui se passe dans le
monde aujourd'hui lorsque j'ai demandé à Chris ce qui était
intéressant dans sa raison.  voulait
y arriver, il a dit que j'ai toujours trouvé cela très
intéressant que lorsqu'ils faisaient
le test Trinity, on leur demandait quelles
étaient les chances que cela se passe mal et que
cela fasse exploser le monde entier, les chances
sont proches de
zéro, que voulez-vous pour la théorie
seul, zéro serait bien, je n'avais pas besoin de
short, quelle est cette décision d'
aller de l'avant et de le faire, c'est un
moment extraordinaire dans l'histoire de l'humanité
et je voulais emmener le public dans
cette salle et être là lorsque ce bouton
est enfoncé et vraiment  amener pleinement le
public à This Moment In Time
pourquoi
[Musique]
nous imaginons un avenir
et nos imaginations sont horrifiantes
dans le cas de ce film, j'ai écrit le
scénario à la première personne, c'est la seule
fois où je l'ai fait, cela a été clair pour
quiconque  qui a lu le scénario, nous sommes dans
cette aventure avec Oppenheimer, c'était très
inhabituel, cela m'a pris une minute pour
comprendre et puis j'ai réalisé que c'était
une énorme responsabilité. Je ne sais pas si on
peut nous faire confiance, mais je sais que les nazis le
peuvent.  Killian jouant Oppenheimer était
la pièce maîtresse du film mais je savais
qu'il allait avoir besoin de
l'ensemble le plus extraordinaire qui soit.
Allons recruter des scientifiques
si Chris Nolan vous appelle et vous dit qu'il
aimerait vous rencontrer comme je le fais.  peu
importe ce que c'est, tu serais fou de dire non
[Musique]
ouais, j'ai l'impression que c'est probablement la
réponse de tout le monde à partir de la
seconde où j'ai lu le scénario, je savais qu'il
avait une vision très aiguë et s'il était
capable de restituer  cette vision selon laquelle ce
film serait un chef-d'œuvre, tous les
acariens industriels américains et
l'innovation scientifique connectés ici gardent tout le monde
là jusqu'à ce qu'il soit terminé, on a l'impression que
chaque personnage est important
parce qu'ils sont tous des personnages historiques
importants, il y a une chance lorsque nous
appuyons sur ce bouton  nous détruisons le monde,
les chances sont proches de zéro.
Ils ont essayé de me familiariser avec
Groves et son histoire, puis ont parlé
à Chris de ce dont il avait besoin de cette
partie. Groves, c'était presque comme un
professeur de maternelle à certains égards
parce que ces scientifiques étaient tellement
excentriques et pas nécessairement
digne de confiance, je veux dire, si vous regardez
d'un point de vue militaire, pourquoi irions-nous
au milieu de nulle part pendant qui
sait combien de temps pourquoi, parce que
c'est la chose la plus importante qui se soit
jamais produite dans l'histoire du
monde, je savais qui  Lewis Strauss
était, j'en suis venu à avoir une compréhension assez équitable
de lui, c'était un
gars juste, je pense que c'était un grand
fonctionnaire mais il est toujours dans les
coulisses, j'ai toujours apprécié les
gens qui sont dans les coulisses, Truman a besoin de
savoir quelle est la prochaine étape.  ce
qui m'a vraiment attiré ensuite avec Kitty Oppenheimer,
c'est qu'elle a refusé de se conformer au genre d'
idéal féminin de l'époque où elle avait cette
défiance contre le système qui semblait si
moderne. Le catalogue de Jean était direct et savait ce qu'elle
voulait, mais à aucun moment, quand l'a-t-elle fait  jamais
puni pour cela et surtout pas par la
théorie d'Oppenheimer ne vous mènera que dans la
mesure où Oppenheimer voit les choses dans des
dimensions différentes, les physiciens opèrent
à un niveau complètement différent du
nôtre et je pense que parfois c'est un fardeau,
donc j'étais vraiment intéressé par ce
que nous  ce que je recherchais, c'était une
performance remarquablement centrée sur le
cœur du film mais aussi une
pièce d'ensemble. J'étais là tous les jours sur le plateau
entouré d'une équipe d'acteurs qui en savaient
plus que moi sur ce qui se passait
de leur point de vue et c'est ça  que
vous recherchez vraiment en tant que réalisateur,
c'est une expérience profondément émouvante et
bouleversante de le regarder
parce que vous vous sentez tellement obligé de regarder
ce qui arrive à ces gens et
comment ils sont entraînés dans le plus grand des
dilemmes moraux et contre quoi ils sont aux
prises.  des personnages
avec la conception sonore et l'école et
l'émotivité de celui-ci ce n'est pas un
film c'est une expérience je l'ai
vu dans sa forme finie
J'étais un peu comme
wow ouais c'est ce que nous espérions cela
pourrait être le monde s'en souviendra
jour
[Musique]